hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for
anime uproar and it is finally
here the first chapter of the direct
sequel to the seven deadly sins manga
has arrived
this chapter calls this new manga the
long-awaited return
of the seven deadly sins so even though
it's called the four knights of the
apocalypse
we can consider this series as a sort of
seven deadly sins
part two in fact the very first
chapter of the sequel directly mentioned
some characters from the original series
so we can be confident that our old
friends from the original manga will
show up
in this series eventually i will be
breaking down the first
chapter and what it all means for all of
us seven deadly sins
fans so let's get into it if you enjoyed
the seven deadly sins content on this
channel and you want us to keep it going
please leave a like and comment
it only takes a second but it really
does help and if you happen to be new to
the channel or maybe you just haven't
subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications if you never want
to miss a seven that these sins or
someone that recent sequel video in the
future
you really have to go through the
trouble of hitting that bell and then
selecting the option that says
all if you don't do that you're still
gonna miss a ton of our videos even if
you are subscribed
it's just how youtube works finally this
video will of course contain spoilers
for the first chapter of the seven
deadly sin sequel so please proceed with
caution
you have been warned the new story
starts off with a brand new hero
named percival and to be perfectly
honest this guy kind of looks like
meliodas if meliodas had
green hair percival is just about to
turn
16 so he's a couple of thousand years
younger than meliotis when we first met
him
and percival lives with only his
grandfather on top of a massive
pillar-shaped mountain that seems to be
completely isolated from the outside
world
but despite being just 16 years old and
despite looking more like a 12 year old
than a 16 year old
percival is already extremely strong and
agile
for example he's able to jump off the
steep mountain grab a massive blue demon
and climb back up the mountain while
carrying the blue demon with one arm
clearly percival strength is far beyond
the strength of an
average human we're not sure at this
point whether he is just a normal human
or whether he has some more interesting
genetics but that's something that we're
going to find out
in the future it's worth mentioning that
percival and his grandpa don't actually
refer
to the bird as a demon they call it a
stone
bird so it's possible that percival
doesn't even know what demons
are at this point in the story we then
get a hint
about why percival is already so strong
at least part of the reason is the fact
that his massively jacked
chad or grandfather has been training
with him every single day of his life
this training includes intense
hand-to-hand combat training through
wrestling sparring and so
on although percival's grandfather can
still beat him in a fight
it is clear that the grandpa has to give
it his all just win
and the grandpa also has to use his
superior size to his advantage
so even though percival's grandpa is an
absolute chad with a lot more combat
experience
percival is already close to surpassing
him in strength despite being
much younger and much smaller again this
hints that there could be something
special about percival he might not be
just a normal
average human we then learn that the
massive pillar-shaped mountain that
percival and his grandpa live on
is called god's finger and its tip is
located
above the clouds in fact from the top of
god's finger
you can see the shadow of sky island or
the sky
temple which is the home to the
celestials from the seven deadly sins
prisoners of the sky
movie if you've been watching this
channel for a while then you know that
i've been saying that the movie
should be considered canon or at least
semi-canon
and that's because many of the things
that were first hinted at
in the movie were later confirmed in the
manga
this is just the latest example of that
the celestials
and their sky temple home are real and
they are indeed canon
in the seven deadly sins sequel now it
seems that percival has never actually
left god's finger
so his grandpa tells him that somewhere
below the mountain there is an entire
land called
britannia and this land has twisting
towers
knights who sail ships of illusions
through the heavens caves with countless
openings that lead to hell
and even an evil lake princess that
tempts heroes and
imprisons them this is a direct
reference to the lady of the lake
who already showed up in the original
seven deadly sins manga
and who also showed up in the lancelot
side story
in fact we can assume that she was the
one who lured lancelot and jericho
away from vaughn and elaine according to
percival's grandpa
both he and percival's father left their
homes when they were 16
to go on an adventure and the same is
expected of percival
at first percival says that he isn't
interested in adventure since he's
perfectly happy living on the mountain
with his grandpa
but secretly he is itching to go on an
epic adventure like
every other great shonen protagonist
percival just doesn't want to make his
grandpa feel bad
since it was his grandpa who cared for
him and raised him for all these years
in this isolated place but everything
changes
when the red knight appears one day a
night wearing red armor and sailing a
flying boat
arrives on the mountain it seems that
that blue demon was a messenger who had
been serving
this night and when the bird was shot
down by percival's grandpa
the red knight was able to somehow trace
this location
this red knight whose real name is
ironside
has been searching for percival's
grandpa for years and it seems that
percival's grandpa decided to raise
percival
in this isolated place in order to hide
him
from the red knight but why did he need
to hide percival
and who is this red knight and what does
he want
that becomes the million dollar question
as
this chapter progresses the knight
already knows that the name of
percival's grandpa
is balgeus and it turns out that both
bulges
and the red knight were once holy
knights of camelot
and those are the knights who serve king
arthur pendragon directly
in fact exactly 16 years ago the red
knight and bulges
parted ways for some reason and that
date roughly corresponds to percival's
current
age which means that the reason that the
two men parted ways
may be directly connected to percival's
birth
at first percival believes the red
knight story that he and bulges are good
friends
and he points the red knight in the
direction of his grandfather
as the knight leaves percival to play
with his floating ship
he casually mentions that bulges is a
cruel man
for raising percival while hiding the
truth
i'm not sure what truth the red knight
was referring to
but it is definitely related to bulger's
past
percival wasn't even aware that the holy
knights existed so it's clear that
bulges has been hiding his past from his
grandson
and there must be a good reason for that
as soon as the red knight sees bulges he
attacks him
and we learned that the sword that
bulges was using as a kitchen knife was
actually an
honored gift from his majesty king
arthur himself
it seems that the red knight and bulges
both betrayed
king arthur 16 years ago although bulges
claims that the red knight and his
faction
turned against arthur while ball just
merely abandoned him
as bulges and the red knight do battle
the knight reveals
a special power he can create
star-shaped cuts of
all sizes on anything he chooses just by
motioning with his fingers
this includes the bodies of his
opponents and much harder surfaces such
as rocks and cliffs
at this point percival tries to
intervene and help his grandpa
but even though he gives it a noble
effort the red knight
is just too strong using his magic power
the red knight creates dozens of cuts on
bulger's body in a matter of
seconds and then he injures percival as
well
leaving a star-shaped cut right across
his chest
but even that cut doesn't deter percival
and he actually tries to punch the
knight despite the pain
of the cut unfortunately this has no
effect on the knight
and he merely kicks percival out of the
way still
the fact that percival is able to
withstand such injuries and just keep
fighting
hints at the fact that he may not be an
ordinary human there is probably
something going on with him
that we are going to find out later on
in the story
when bulges asks the red knight why he
came to kill him
now the knight reveals that an ominous
prophecy was made
only a few days ago the prophecy told of
an existence that will lead
king arthur to his doom and the name of
this existence
is the four knights of the apocalypse
the red knight claims that for all he
knows bulges is one of the four knights
so he has to be
taken out but that sounds pretty
suspicious to me
why would the red knight care about
protecting king arthur when he was the
one who turned against him
16 years ago this kind of smells fishy
to me
confident that bulges has been fatally
wounded ironside the red knight
leaves thankfully percival despite being
injured
seems to be okay but his grandpa is not
so lucky bulges eventually succumbs to
his many wounds but before he does
he reveals that the red knight is
apparently percival's
father it's not true first of all ken
believed
this man who has done such terrible
things could be his father
but unfortunately bulges doesn't have
enough time left to explain everything
he simply tells percival to prepare to
start his journey
and to seek out the answers for himself
tragically
bulges then dies in his grandson's arms
and with his final breath he calls
percival his dear grandson
and his hope percival is understandably
heartbroken
at the loss of his grandfather this is
the man who raised him and he is
practically the only person that
percival has ever interacted with
because the two of them spent so much
time
in complete isolation after burying his
grandfather
percival takes his helmet and cape and
he sets out on his adventure
down the mountain and into the world of
britannia
i would like to think that he also took
his grandfather's sword
the one that was given to him by king
arthur although this is not explicitly
shown so a very interesting first
chapter
and a lot of fascinating lingering
questions that i can't wait to learn
more about
first of all why was bulges hiding
percival
that seems to be what he was doing on
god's finger but the red knight didn't
seem all that interested in percival
so was bulges hiding percival from his
father or from someone or something else
speaking of which is the red knight
really percival's father
or is the story more complicated like
for example
is ironside being controlled by some
evil
force or something like that there is
definitely a demon connection there with
that blue demon that showed up earlier
but we'll have to wait and see and of
course i am also very interested in
percival
why is he so strong at his age is he
just an ordinary human who trained
really hard
or is there something more to his
genetics something that makes him
special
in arthurian legend percival is one of
king arthur's knights of the round table
just like tristan and lancelot since
tristan and lancelot are the children of
the original sins
we can assume that percival will be
meeting them at some point in the future
and that together they will become the
heroes of the new story
are the four horsemen of the apocalypse
really going to bring doom
to king arthur are they the villains of
the story
or was the red knight lying maybe the
four knights of the apocalypse are
actually the heroes of the story
just like the seven deadly sins turned
out to be the heroes in the original
story
so are percival lancelot and tristan
going to end up being three of the four
members
of the knights of the apocalypse
presumably the child of king and the and
would become the fourth member since we
know they do have a child
we just haven't met them yet i think
that would be super cool and it would be
consistent with the seventh deadly sins
twist in the beginning of the original
story
at first we think that the seven deadly
sins are wanted traitors but then we
realized that they were framed
and they are actually the heroes that
said i'm also very interested in the red
knight ironside in arthurian legend he
is one of the early enemies of percival
in the legend the red knight stole a cup
from king arthur
so the idea of the red knight betraying
king arthur is present in the original
legend as well
and in arthurian legend percival
eventually kills the red knight
and takes his red armor for himself
we know that the seven deadly sin story
was never a one-for-one retelling of the
arthurian legend
but it was always heavily inspired by it
so we can assume that something similar
might happen here percival may end up
defeating the red knight his alleged
father
retrieving whatever it is that he stole
from king arthur and taking his red
armor for himself
now in the original arthurian legend
percival
is raised in a forest by his mother
until he is 15.
and just like the percival in the manga
he is raised completely ignorant of the
ways of the world
but when he sees a group of knights
passing through the forest
percival is impressed by them and he
decides to become a knight himself
eventually he ends up in camelot and
becomes one of arthur's
knights of the round table this seems to
be the type of path that the manga
percival
is following as well he was raised in
isolation until the age of 16
and he is now setting off an adventure
that will probably lead him to becoming
one of the knights of the round
table in arthurian legend percival is
also connected to the quest for the holy
grail
so this may end up playing an important
role in the sequel story
whatever happens i'm excited to find out
more about percival's origins about the
red knight
and the mysterious prophecy i also can't
wait to see how lancelot
tristan and the other characters from
the original seven deadly sin series
will fit into
this story i wonder if the four knights
of the apocalypse will actually be this
story's version
of the knights of the round table since
arthur is the king of chaos
in this story maybe his knights will be
called
the knights of the apocalypse and then
percival will be one of them
along with tristan lancelot and the
child of king and the anne
my guess is that the prophecy that was
mentioned is
a bit misleading but we'll have to wait
and see
definitely let me know what you guys
thought of this first chapter and are
you excited for this
new seven deadly sins story
what do you think is going to happen
next and do you think that there is more
to percival's origins than we realize
is he really just a human or does he
have some more
complicated genetics and how do you guys
think that our heroes from the original
seven deadly sins are going to fit
into this story share your thoughts and
opinions down below
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more seven deadly sins sequel
videos on this channel
please leave that like it only takes a
second but it helps a lot
and if you're new to anime pro or maybe
you haven't subscribed yet make
this the video that you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications you can also hit me up
on twitter and
instagram at animeopror a big thank you
to all of our anime uproar patrons who
make videos like this one possible
special thanks to alpha sigma disciple
of lord twego himself
and i can't forget our the one tier
patrons the ones who stand above
all other clans including ingrata
the world acquired respect pate heffa
dr cortman rathee and y x emperor otaku
spotty life canal big buddhist and
tungsten tarcus
finally thank you to our pro hero tier
patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh steelers angel cruz anatoly
kazatsky
joe stanton very gucci jessica calefon
rathundera alicia octor
bonnie park sinokami and water the
red-haired raven florian joanne garcia
jack watches anime fat boy games deadly
saint matthew crews anthony schreiber hi
jinx and mr waffles 247.
if you feel that our videos provide
value for you consider supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patreon exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you